[Musique]
je chanter une chanson dont le titre est
tellement grand qu'on peut pas le mettre
sur la pochette s'appelle chanter pour
ceux qui sont loin de chez eux vas-y
Michel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Berger
celuil nuit à regarder les étoiles en
pensant qu'au bout du monde il y a
quelqu'un qui pense à
[Musique]
lui et cette petite fille qui joue qui
ne veut plus jamais souris et qui voit
son père partout qui s'est construit un
empire
[Musique]
ou
qu'ils ils sont tristes à la faitte pour
qu'ils
aillent ils sont seuls dans leur
tête je veux chanter pour
ceux qui sont loin de chez
eux et qui ont dans leurs
yeux quelque chose qui fait mal qui fait
mal je veux chanter pour
ce
qu'on oublie peu à
peu et qui garde au fond
[Musique]
d'eux quelque chose qui fait mal qui
fait
[Musique]
mal qui a volé leur histoire qui a volé
leur mémoire qui a fétiné leur vie comme
on marche sur un
[Musique]
miroir celui-là voudra des bombes
celui-là comptera les jours en alignant
des bâtons comme les barreaux d'une
prison où qu'ils
aillent ils sont tristes à la fête où
qu'ils
allent ils sont seuls dans leur
tête je veux chanter pour
ceux qui sont loin de chez
eux et qui ont dans leurs
yeux quelque chose qui fait mal qui fait
mal je veux chanter pour
ceux qu'on oublie peu à
peu
et qui garde au fond
d'eux quelque chose qui fait mal qui
fait ma vi chanz pour
ceux qui sont loin de chez
eux et qui ont dans leurs
yeux quelque chose qui fait mal qui fait
mal quand je pense à
eux
[Musique]
ça fait mal ça fait mal quand je pense à
eux ça fait mal ça fait
[Musique]
mal